so what are we going to do today well
basically we're going to make a journey
a journey all the way from the source
code of python to the execution and for
me it's kind of like writing magic
spells I used to play games like DND and
stuff like that and with programming
languages you get to write something and
then something happens often it's not
what I want but at least something
happens so that's what we're going to
see today I'm going to take you on a
journey I'm going to show you how python
gets from the source code all the way to
the magic all the way to the execution
I'm not just going to give you a lecture
about that I think that would be rather
boring but I'm going to show you how to
implement a new operator in Python and
that will naturally take us all the way
from that source code to that execution
however do note I have a series
disclaimer for this talk we have time
constraints so I'm going to Omit things
there will be blatant's emissions there
will be gross oversimplifications I will
take shortcuts the implementation will
not be ideal but hopefully it will give
you an overview of what happens within
Indie python internals
all right
if you do like to know more details if
you're interested after this talk
definitely check out the python
developers guide on
deafguide.python.org it contains a lot
of information about how you can mess
with the python internals how to compile
it but it also has excellent
explanations about the parser grammar
and everything else and then obviously
there's Anthony Shell's Book C python
internals published by real python it's
a great book definitely check it out if
you're interested in this
all right so what is our journey today
well we're going to go from source code
to execution basically in two parts in
the first part we're going to look at
the tokenizer and the parser to create
something called an abstract syntax tree
and then in the second part we're going
to take that abstract syntax tree and go
all the way to the magic using the
compiler and evaluation Loop by the way
if you want to check out the slides or
the source code for the the version of
python that we're creating today check
out the GitHub repository everything's
there a couple of versions of the slides
one version of The Source Code but do
note it's an educational implementation
don't use it in production I'm not
maintaining it it's a crappy
implementation please don't use it for
anything serious
all right what is a pipe operator
well a pipe operator is something that's
part of a lot of languages but not
Python and it's basically another way of
calling functions so say you have a
function that takes one argument like
this double over here just takes a
number and it multiplies the number by
two and it returns to Value well the
pipe operator allows you to call this
function in a different way you provide
a value on the right hand side of the
operator then you use the operator
itself then you name the function and
then the argument will be passed into
the function and you get the result out
of it but this is obviously not really
interesting just like calling the
function double one but what you can do
with this is you can build pipelines so
you can start with a single value and
you can pipe it into various functions
to process it you get something out the
other end so in this case this would be
equivalent to calling double one and
then insert that into another double
call the nested function call so this is
what we're going to do today
well just to be clear this is not a part
of python I don't think it will ever be
a part of python there were a few
proposals for this they were rejected
for good reasons maybe in the future who
knows ask a core developer not me and
the implementation is purely educational
I've already mentioned that
show the first part we want to get from
the source code
so the characters on the right hand side
all the way to that abstract syntax tree
that you see there so this tree-like
representation of your source code so if
you have a single python file with this
line in it only this line you'll get
something like you see there the three
representation of your source code you
have a module a single expression it's a
binary operation an operation with two
operands of value to the right hand side
and a value to the left hand side and
that binary operation has a constant at
10 it has the operator itself the call
pipe and then it loads the name the name
of the function obviously this won't
work in a foul in its own because there
is no function here but this is the
general idea of what we're trying to do
in the first part we're trying to get
from that part to that nice tree over
there
so first look at our source code
we humans we are very good in Reading we
recognize patterns we immediately see
that we have a 10 that we have a name
double that we have a weird operator in
the middle that is unfamiliar in Python
but at least we immediately recognize a
bit but if you think about it for python
at the start this is just a stream of
individual characters there are 12
characters here and they make up our
source code and python has to understand
those characters and the first step
python takes is basically extracting the
tokens from this source code and tokens
are the minimal parts that still have a
meaning so for instance we have a number
token over here if you split this up
even further into a one and a zero you
lose the meaning of the number 10. we
have a name over here obviously if you
remove a character it's no longer the
same name so this is a name token and
the first thing that we need to
implement is that python will recognize
this token here in the middle this
operator this two character operator has
one single token
this isn't very difficult to do this is
just a configuration in a file if you
look in the python repository there's a
file grammar slash tokens and it's just
a big mapping of token names to token
character sequences
so all that we have to do is we have to
add our own token into this file
and there's no meaning here yet this is
just a description of a token so I've
called it V bar grader fill the vertical
bar grader and I've mapped it to the
Token sequence that we want to introduce
this isn't uh all of it but what we
still need to do is regenerate the
tokenizer itself the actual uh piece of
python that will get this tokens from
your source code because python will not
read this file every time it tries to
power source code for that we just have
to run some commands and this will be a
recurring theme in this presentation
change something run a command and then
you can see the result
so these are the commands I'm not going
to go into detail in all those in all
these commands because you can find them
on the Internet and you're not going to
remember them here anyway but after
we've done this python will now be able
to recognize our new token our V bar
grader token that's already a big step
but it doesn't really know what to do
with that token so there's no grammar
rule that tells python if you see this
token then this has to happen
so the next thing that we will need to
do is we need to add support for this
new token in Python sparser by adding it
to Python's grammar while the grammar
also has to produce something which is
the abstract syntax tree that we saw
earlier so we also have to tell the
grammar how to generate the abstract
syntax tree and make sure that there's
something for our cold pipe available in
that abstract syntax tree
so let's look at our grammar yet
so since python 3.0 I forgot 3.9 the new
pack parser has been introduced and this
has a completely new grammar it's very
flexible it's very powerful but we first
have to look into the syntax of this
grammar just a little bit to add our own
rule so I'm just going to take a very
small dive into the Parson expression
grammar that python uses just enough to
know to Define our new rule for the cold
pipe operator
so if you imagine a very simple
programming language and it only has two
expression types it has a sum and it has
something called an atom
and in this very simple language there
are only two grammar rules
the sum and the atom there might be some
other for statements and stuff like that
but we we're going to ignore that for
now we're going to focus on these two
then this is basically what you can
Define in pack parser this is a little
bit simplified but these could be
grammar rules and just to color code
them grammar rules can reference each
other and this is how python goes down
all the grammar rules to see what it
matches so its first try starts by
trying to match the sum row and within
the sum rule there are options that
reference the atom rule which is just a
number and that is how we ever consider
the atom rule so if we just have this
single piece of uh
source code it's just a number it will
first try to to match the sum rule it
has two Alternatives it's what the
vertical bars mean it has an atom plus
an atom and it has an atom on its own so
this matches the second alternative in a
sum rule which is an atom then we look
at the atom because it's just a number
so we can parse this
so in this very simple Grammar example
we can parse a number on its own
how what about this one
on this one we have an atom a number
plus and then another atom which matches
the first rule of the sum so it's very
easy to see that this grammar rule will
now be able to match this simple piece
of grammar as well
but now what about this one
think about it for a moment
are our grammar rules able to parse this
very simple statement
I see some people shaking yes other
shaking no well the problem here is that
when you start parsing your expression
you will consume these parts we can
parse this very easily and what we're
done left with is a plus and a three and
we have no rule that matches a plus and
a three on its own
so how are we going to match something
with two pluses obviously we can add
another rule
but what if we want an atom plus an atom
plus an atom plus another atom do we
have to add another Rule and if we want
four pluses or five or six or if we want
an infinite pluses we'd be busy quite a
long time if we wanted to add
alternatives for all those different
scenarios
but there's a very simple solution for
that and you're probably going to love
this it's just recursion so what we can
do is we can change the first uh
alternative in some rule we can make it
reference itself
and now we can have sums that are
embedded in other sums embedded in other
sums and just remember a sum can also
just be an atom on its own so we can
still match an atom plus an atom
but now we can also match a sum
contained in another sum
and this is basically all that you need
to do to get an arbitrary number of
operators in a row and if you think
about it this is precisely what we need
for our new pipe operator
we also want to be able to build an
arbitrary long pipeline so the grammar
rule that we will need to add is a
grammar rule that has such a recursive
relationship
so let's see that this is the existing
grammar file in Python grammar slash
python.gram here you see the shift
expression if you want to do bit
shifting and you see the sum expression
and I'm just going to insert our new
grammar rule between those two so let's
make some space this is probably isn't
the best place to insert it but it means
that it's very easy to insert it so
that's why I've chosen it
so here we're going to add a new rule
let's call it pipe and as you can see
here this is just our recursive
relationship
there's just one problem our grammar
rule isn't referenced by any other
grammar rule in Python so the the parser
will never consider it when parsing
source code so what do we have to do
well if you look at the shift expression
it actually references the sum
expression that's how the grammar rules
flow down so the only thing that we need
to do to insert it we have to change the
references in the shift expression to
the pipeline and in the pipe can then
reference to someone so if we change
this the shift expression now references
to Pi one the pipe is someone and now
our grammar rules can flow down again
and this is basically the only thing
that we need to do to add our new
grammar rule for our new pipeco operator
so now we can parse this right we're
done
well not quite
but because we also still need to be
able to create the the tree structure
that you see there on the right we have
to be able to fit it into our abstract
syntax tree so how are we going to do
that
in the old parser there used to be an
intermediate step the concrete syntax
tree but with the new PEC parser we
don't need that anymore and the reason
why is that because we now have
something called grammar actions if you
look here this is a grammar action
between the curly braces and because
we're targeting C python this is
basically just a piece of C code that is
embedded into the grammar file so
whenever python matches a sum rule it
will then call this C function to create
a classes that we see there to create
the three three structure that we see
there well to create a binary operation
tree structure we need the right hand
side of the operator so the value we
need we need the left hand side and we
need the operator so that's the
information that we're going to pass
into this function and that we can do by
assigning names to the parts that we
match in our expression so we match an a
to the right hand side pass it into the
function we match your B to the left
hand side pass it into the function we
know that this is is an ad operation
because this is the sum rule so we can
hard go through the add operator and
there are some extra bits having to do
with line number and stuff like that
we're going to ignore that for now but
they're very handy for tracebacks and
other kinds of interesting things so
this is all we need to create a binary
operation with an add operator can we
now do that for our own rule obviously
we can just copy the approach because
our new operator is also a binary
operation so we can just make it call
the same function but instead of using
the add operator we can use the call
pipe operator here
just one tiny problem
the AST uses classes and there is no
class called call pipe yet it just
doesn't exist yet so we have to create
that so that we can actually build this
abstract syntax tree with that call
patent note somewhere in the middle for
the operator field so how do we do that
is it difficult do we have to decode a
lot luckily not because this is another
configuration file this is in parser
slash
python.asdl which stands for abstract
syntax definition language
and as you can see here somewhere in the
middle there's a part for the operator
and here's our at Option just in an
option list and this is all you need to
do to uh have a generator create classes
for you so what do we have to do
just add our new operator at the end as
another option
then we regenerate the ASD we run
another command and now our classes will
be created for us
so this is all we have to do to add
support in the ASD
now we can regenerate the entire parser
and now we are actually able to parse
expressions with the call pipe operator
in it you can see here that we have a
binary bin up node somewhere in our ast3
and it actually uses a core pipe class
object in there to represent the
operator so this is all that we need to
do for the new grammar
and now we're done now we can go from
source code to an abstract syntax tree
but this is all fairly static nothing
happened yet so to do that we need to
move on to part two where we're actually
going to run where we're actually going
to transform this into something we can
run and then actually execute it
so in part two we will look at the
compiler so if you've ever joined an
online discussion about is python a
compiled language or not please don't
they're all very toxic but we are going
to compile this into some form of an
Intermediate Language we're going to
compile this into a little bit of byte
code
and to do that we need to have a byte
code for our new operator because
bytecode is just a long list of
instructions for python a long sequence
of bytes a long sequence of numbers and
each instruction that we're going to
execute has its own number or its own
byte and we need one for our new
operation and obviously there is already
a bytecode for calling functions but I'm
going to ignore that one because it
isn't fun to use what's already in
Python so we're going to add support to
the compiler by creating our own
instruction then we're going to make the
compiler actually use that instruction
write it into the bytecode and then
we're going to uh to add support in the
evaluation Loop to actually do something
with that code
so let's do that this is the only python
file that we'll see today we can use it
to Define our operation codes our op
codes our op code doesn't have an
argument don't worry about that for now
but it means it has to have a number
lower than the half argument constant so
I'm just going to add it here I'm going
to call it binary pipe call that's for
us so that we can understand it and the
byte go to the number that we associate
with the operation is 90. and I have to
increase all the numbers below it and
it's a tedious job but we'll have to do
it
now we can regenerate all the opcodes do
you see the pattern yet and now the
opcout will actually be generated for us
right now we have an opcode now we still
need to make the compiler actually write
that opcode into the bytecode
so how are we going to do that
well the compiler is just going to visit
all the nodes in our ASD and it has
functions that handle that visit and
somewhere in our compiler there's a
function called compiler visit expert 1
expression one which eventually gets
called to handle Expressions we don't
actually have to change it but there's
an important fact here if you look at
this function it's just a massive switch
case operations and for each type of
expression including the binary B bin up
kind there's a special case and here's
our case we first are going to visit the
left hand side of the operator which is
really important because we need that
value write all the instructions for it
then we're going to visit the right hand
side write all the instructions to
evaluate the right hand side and then
we're going to add the operation for the
operator
and to know which opcode to write
there's a helper function bin up and
this is the function that we actually
need to change
this is another switch case statement
this will get an AST note like this ad
here and it will return the bin up that
we actually want to execute or add to
the bytecode so we need to add another
case
writer binary pipe call operator and now
we can write it into the bytecode
there's one final thing that we need to
change in the compiler it's the stack
effect python uses a value stack you'll
see that later and the effect of our
operation is that our values stack
decreases by one value but don't worry
about that for now
and this is the compiler and now we can
go from an AST to a long list of
instructions and this is all we need to
write our new operator our new opcode
into the bytecode and now we get to the
evaluation Loop and this is really where
the magic happens the evaluation Loop
like the name says is just one giant
Loop that goes around and around and
around and around executing all the
instructions in the bytecode and inside
of that Loop there is a massive switch
case statement and I'm not exaggerating
it's really massive look at the source
code in
python.c and for each opcode it has a
case so for instance here is the binary
subtract and this is the code that
actually gets executed whenever it sees
such an opcode for a binary subtract
something minus something else
but here we have a problem
because how do we get the values that
were to the right and to the left of the
operator how do we get them back to
actually process them here well this is
why python uses a value stack
and from that value stack we can get the
values that we need to perform the
operation now how does that work say
that we have this simple expression four
minus one what we saw earlier I said
python will first write the instructions
to evaluate the left hand side when it's
done it will put that value onto the
value stack
to remember it then it will evaluate the
right hand side and it will put it on to
the value stack and the value stack is
really a stack it will put a 3 on top of
the four on the value stack just so that
we're able to use them later
so when we enter this new function for
the operator the three and the four are
on our value stack so now that we can
use the pop macro just to get the three
out of the value stack and make right
point to that value
for left we do something similar we
leave it on the value stack but we make
left refer to that value that's there on
the value stack
now we have our values we can call a c
API function Pi number subtract pass in
the two values we get a result out of it
result will now point to the one
we are now done with those values we can
decrease the reference counts for the
values and then at the end we need to do
something with the result with the
resulting value so what do we do we just
put it back on the value stack we're
going to replace the value that was
already there so after performing the
operation there's one less value on the
value stack and that was the minus one
that we saw earlier then there's some
error handling and then we do a dispatch
to say to the evaluation please move on
to the next value
so how do we do that for a binary pipe
call oh you just copy paste this code
because this does basically what we need
we change the targets to our binary pipe
cooperator we get the values like we did
before but now we don't want to subtract
them we want to call a function with a
value
there's a very handy C API function in
Python 3.9 it's not in the the long term
stable one so it might be deprecated but
it's very handy here and here you can
call a function with one argument
uh and remember the function was on the
right hand side so we pass and function
right first the value was on the left
hand side so we pass it in second we get
the result decrease the reference counts
and we put the resulting value back on
the value value stack
and this is all we need to do to get
from the ASD to the magic
and now we've completed our journey we
can go all the way from source code to
execution and all the steps that are in
between there's just one thing left to
do let's compile our new version of
python and if you're waiting for it you
can you might as well just have a sword
fight and after that's done you can run
your new version of python and you can
use your operator it will actually work
if you follow these steps there are some
quirks especially in operator precedence
with this implementation but it will
work in principle
and basically that's it we've seen a lot
of python internals in a short time
don't worry about it this is just for a
framework check out the books the dev
guide source source code and slides are
available and If you get weird errors
try running may clean or clean all on
Windows
and look into something called the magic
number because we've changed the
bytecode version so we need to change
the bytecode version in see python as
well
before we go I hope you've been you've
enjoyed your python it's been great for
me but we also need to organize the next
Edition in
2033. I don't know when or where it's
going to be but if you want to be a
volunteer just like me join us to help
organize python 23 you can send an email
there or you can just talk to me after
my talk and that's it I hope you've
enjoyed my talk thank you very much
[Applause]